la sexualité des handicapés le sujet est
tabou et ce depuis toujours en france
est ce que tu as déjà fait l'amour avec
un garçon et jaminon la première
reconnaissance des désirs sexuels des
handicapés par le corps médical
c'est en 1981 à l'issue d'un congrès
entre sexologue médecins et psychologues
ce qui reste vrai ce qui reste tout à
fait dominant c'est qu'au niveau de
l'affection au niveau de l'amour les
exigences sont les mêmes quelle que soit
les handicaps physiques ou sensorielles
dès lors se pose la question de
l'accompagnement des personnes
handicapées dans leur sexualité comment
faciliter l'acte entre deux personnes en
couple pour les célibataires quelle aide
apporter la solution pourrait passer par
les assistants sexuels comme c'est le
cas aux pays-bas depuis 1993 nous
faisons plus que les prostituées on
parle on prend le café
je pense que c'est une véritable aide
sociale des professionnels formés aux
gestes aux soins et aux différents
handicaps
en france des associations revendiquent
cette assistance comme l'expliquent en
2007 l'un des militants de la première
heure
marcel nuss l'accompagnement sexuel est
un soulagement des frustrations me
refourguer personnes saint père ni
jusqu'au jusqu'à la masturbation
masturbation pénétration ou à minima
caresses et discussions or la france
refuse de créer un statut pour des
assistants sexuels
en l'absence de cadres deux alternatives
des bénévoles souvent issus du milieu
médical accompagnent les handicapés ou
les travailleurs du sexe dans un cas
comme dans l'autre c'est illégal car
apparenté à de la prostitution
cet homme en 2009 par exemple assume
braver la loi pour mettre son patient en
relation avec des femmes à ce titre là
je rentre dans le coup de la loi
ce contre le proxénétisme ne peut pas
laisser une souffrance comme ça sans
réponse malgré la pression des
associations pas de statut pour des
assistants sexuels en france en
attendant les accompagnons hors la loi
se forme avec des militants afin de
prodiguer au mieux les soins ou
handicapées en demande comme ici en
alsace en 2015
aujourd'hui il ya déjà beaucoup de très
beaux sexy en compte des handicapés mais
le problème c'est que tout est caché
tout se fait de façon hypocrite la
sexualité limité par les barrières du
corps ou de l'esprit
à ce jour aucun projet de loi sur la
sexualité des handicapés n'a été
présenté aux parlementaires en france
tout juste des rapports sans aucune
suite
[Musique]